правда зручно купляти маєтки в Києві під
час війни коли декларацію можна не
подавати як ми є ток халімонов в центрі
холера Києва вони бояться відповісти за
корупцію не переймайте за безпеку
мінобороні стає гірше скандалів
корупційних буде більше ми про них
знаємо ми тепер будемо про них говорити
надто дорого ми платимо за державу щоби
політики які очолюють
називались на наших грошах
деталі Протягом останнього тижня ми
стали свідками одразу кількох
резонансних таких корупційних історій це
Міноборони зі своїми закупівлями і
Василь Лозинський який погорів на хабарі
за генератори і наприклад слуга народу
Павло Халімон який орендував маєток на
Печерську за великі гроші плюс ми бачимо
цілий парад різних звільнень і відставок
чому усе це ми бачимо саме зараз
парад звільнення і відставок часто не
причетних до корупційних скандалів людей
Ну до цих конкретно трьох
це відповідь на ці кейси як на мене
давайте розберемо кожний кейс окремо
тому що кожен він
кожен специфічний дуже важливий давайте
там де реакція влади найкраща
на вашу думку де найкраща кейс
лозинського це дуже просто дивіться між
моментом затримання лозинського
антикорупційним бюро до моменту
публічної позиції про його звільнення
пройшла година
за годину після реалізації Міністерство
вийшло з позицією на ранок його
звільнять на ранок його звільнили
ідеальна історія От такої має бути
реакція влади
саме такою
беремо
огидний кейс кейс резнікова в суботу
виходить розслідування розслідування
Дзеркало тижня виходить чотири дні
резніков або мовчить а потім коли
скандал захищає наростає захищає цю
схему і її авторів і тільки під тиском
суспільства на четвертий день він не
звільняє А сам звільняється
відповідальний заступник це огидна
реакція яка нічого не вирішує показує що
міністр резніков є частиною проблеми а
не її рішення відчуваєте різницю
кубракових за годину звільняє сам цей
різні під тиском це означає що проблема
не в заммі а в резнікові
а це означає що довіра до цього міністра
підірвана А я вам нагадаю в чому різниця
між резніковим і кубраковим закупки
резнікова таємні їх не видно вони
сховані який ми зловили один контракт а
там таких сотні з якого диво тепер має
вірити міністру який очевидно брехав про
один контракт
розповідаючи про це технічна помилка там
яйця кілограми ну це до речі яка
технічна помилка на пару мільярдів
помилка сьогодні мільйонів Перепрошую бо
там яйця а решта там де картопля по 22
грн за кілограм або стегенця курячі по
120 за кілограм там що Бо це так і не
пояснив міністр
або ціни на капусту які вдвічі вище
ринкових або ціни на буряк і там інші
набір продуктів це ж не було пояснено
навіть брехнею Пробачте що видно брехня
про помилку тому
різні порушив суспільне договір який є
між нами і владою під час війни суть
договору ми вас не критикуємо якби ми як
ми це робили до війни натомість ви
жорстко реагуєте на будь-які прояві
корупції так як Зробив кубраков не так
як зробив різніков відповідно вся сама
цензура всі самообмеження по схемах і
проблемах Міноборони резніков зняв Хай
тепер вигрібає все що ми не говорили
раніше а скандалів буде багато До чого
це може призвести цей тиск суспільства
на Міноборони до чого він може призвести
це не тиск це розповіді про проблеми в
псевдоні Міноборони ми не тиснемо Ми
розказуємо які там є проблеми це би мало
зараз привести до відставки різнікова
президента прямо зараз
бо на рівні різні коли це вже не буде
вирішено це ж Очевидно вони навіть не
звільнили замок вони розказували що він
бере на себе несправедливі звинувачення
і іде Час розплачують просто
різні проблеми і тепер він проблема для
всієї країни бо ця ж історія
вилізла в глобальні медіа сьогодні і
завтра про це напишуть всі глобальні
Меді Ми спілкуємося з ними усіма всі
беруть коментарі от якраз таке питання
як це може вплинути на міжнародну
підтримку України на підтримку зброю на
підтримку євроінтеграції Ось ця
конкретна студент Мені здається
негативно очевидно бо історія і про
лозинського вийде в глобальні медіа але
ця історія буде позитивною взяли на
хабарі антикорупційні інституції
міністр віце-прем'єр за годину звільнив
ідеальна історія правда це історія яка
будує довіру до української влади до
України та довіру яка конвертується в
гроші і зброю
але паралельно буде інша історія
міністр закупив продукти для солдат
вдвічі дорожче навіть не ринку
роздрібних мереж в Києві чотири дні
захищав виправдовуючи несучі абсолютно
несенітниці ще й погрожувала журналісту
СБУ а потім під тиском звільнив замах
правда інше буде інше сприйняття буде
якщо ми говоримо про звільнення голів
обласних військових адміністрацій це все
люди Тимошенко Тимошенко звільнили їх по
звільняли було за що чи просто
закономічна історія
це той який перекинув на компанію не
знаю коханки подруги співмешканки гроші
на ремонт доріг і його ж не звільняли
скільки півтора місяці після цієї
історії ще з листопада здається ну
звільнили що зараз тому що Тимошенко
пішов Пішли Тимошенко яке майбутнє
Тимошенко якого пішли Я сумніваюсь що
він в країні лишиться
прям сумніваюсь я думаю що він швидко
звідси якщо ми говоримо загалом про
корупцію під час війни вона стала
більшою вона зменшилася вона краще
приховується яка зараз ситуація беремо
закупки Міноборони де суспільний договір
різні
відверто будемо говорити що відбувається
закупки влітку Минулого року
аналогічні як це на якій він спалився
цього разу були нормальними аналогічні
контракти в них цілі з ринковими не
різнилися
тобто тоді було нормально зараз очевидно
як на мене корупційна змова тому в
мінобороні стає гірше скандалів
корупційних буде більш ми про них знаємо
ми тепер будемо про них говорити ми не
бачимо цих контрактів правда ж закупівлі
їжі до війни таємними не були їх сховали
що концептуально неправильно ми ж не
просимо кількість Куди воно йде хто
підрядник нас цікавить ціна за одиницю
товару всі інші Ми самі з'ясуємо з
хорошого комітет парламентський
антикорупції і комітет оболонки підпише
законопроект який ми в тому числі
розробляли який поверне трошки
публічності всі закупівлі оце нічого не
вирішує по величезний шмат закупівель
Міноборони є таємним зброя оснащення
амуніція і правильно що ці закупівлі
таємні одна проблема Чому я маю вірити
після цього різні якщо ми говоримо про
інші корупційні
рейси зловживання службовим становищем
той самий Халімон чи чи Симоненко так
який літав чи їздив в Іспанію у
відпустку
ці публічні звільнення покарання вони
достатньо
в восени був скандал восени Коли Ні не
восени раніше Коли ще багін прокурор
кабіні діктовав коли набу а операцію
набу було зірвано по ньому
за відповідальністю генпрокурора який
вони діктової
зараз вилізло помогло захист його від
індиктової слуга народу краще стало інша
історія вони сховали декларації свої на
початку війни не просто сховали а
відмінили обов'язок їх подавати правда
зручно купляти маєтки в Києві під час
війни коли декларацію можна не подавати
у мене питання до депутатів слух народу
друзі А що ми заважає декларації подати
вони переймаються про свою безпеку да
вони бояться відповісти за корупцію не
переймайте за безпеку аргументів немає
крім бажання сховати майно набути під
час війни як маєток халімона в центрі
холера Києва голова фракція слуга народу
до видрахемі обіцяв чергові весняні
посадки чого нам чекати на весну
по-хорошому з арахабі якраз зареєстрував
законопроект і повертає декларування от
йому плюс скарму він зареєстрував його в
грудні мені здається
плюс йому в кару посадки він просто не
може нікого посадити
це робить правоохоронна система разом з
судами Ну він не може нікого посадити
навіть якщо він хотів А політична воля
політична він зробити це перше захищати
антикорупційну інфраструктуру друге
добити повернення декларування і третє
відкоригувати кримінально-процесуальний
кодекс оце реально що він може робити
щоб були посадки от я думаю що він би на
цьому мав би і сконцентруватись адже
варто чекати справедливого покарання для
тих хто погорів на ось таких резонансних
корупційних кейсах
арештований під вартою в заставі в 100
мільйонів гривень
прямо під варто взяли в залі суду як
війна змінить нашу боротьбу з корупцією
поки триває війна в суспільства адженда
виживання що нормально сім'ї немає
електрики загрози бомбардувань загрози
Контрнаступ все зрозуміло адженда
виживання як тільки буде Перемога або її
буде видно На перше місце вийде адже на
справедливості надто дорого ми платимо
за державу
щоби політики які очолюють
називались на наших грошах і ось в цей
момент запит несправедливість буде ще
жорсткіший ще сильніший ще акцентовніший
ніж після революції гідності Дякую вам
за розмову дякую вам